what is being called the mask affair
surfaced at the end of february
when police searched the offices of
georg newsline a member of parliament
and prominent figure in the conservative
csu party
newsline is being probed for bribery he
is thought to have accepted over six
hundred thousand euros by a mass
producer to lobby for its product
but the affair doesn't stop here nicolas
lubel a lawmaker with chancellor angela
merkel's cdu party
admitted his company received 250 000
euros
to act as a mediator for mask purchases
prosecutors are now carrying out an
initial review of his case
both newsline and louisville have
announced their departure from the
conservative bloc's parliamentary group
but while lubel resigned from parliament
effective immediately
nuslin plans to keep his seat for the
opposition ftp party
this is not enough further scrutiny is
needed
clarity must be provided to the public
millions of people
fear for their existence and have seen
their freedom restricted
and the impression can't be that the few
who want to do business from parliament
using its letterhead are exploiting this
crisis for their own benefits
the sister parties cdu and csu say they
want to conduct a comprehensive
investigation into such practices
and introduce a code of conduct that
would prevent them
we need to go a whole step further and
make it clear that what is legally
possible is not necessarily acceptable
for us
we need a code of conduct that clearly
states that it's not
possible or acceptable under any
circumstances
to benefit financially from the already
active role
as a member of parliament
the scandal risks battering mackel's cdu
party
ahead of two important regional
elections taking place on sunday
in the states of baden-wurttemberg and
ryland palatinate
recent polls have shown a dip in the
party's numbers not good news for the
cdu
just six months before the country's
parliamentary elections
for more now let's pull in our political
correspondent simon young good evening
to you simon yeah this looks
really bad i mean how damaging are these
corruption claims
for germany's conservative parties
very bad i think brent members of
parliament
potentially profiting financially from
the corona crisis that's a very bad look
and there are warnings that it could
throw a negative light
on all politicians but it does seem to
be a particular problem
of the conservative parties clearly it
could impact their electoral standing in
this
big election year there's federal
elections in september but uh
there's a couple of regional elections
coming up this weekend so we may see
something there
especially in baden-wurttemberg where
the cdu
is in coalition with the greens and
they may be worried about losing support
in that context we'll have to wait and
see what happens
at the weekend but going forward i think
angela merkel's party
does need to show that it's learning the
lessons from this
from this scandal that it's going to
introduce tougher rules uh code of
conduct
and uh improve its behavior because this
is about trust
yeah i mean i i'm sure most people would
agree no one should be earning hundreds
of thousands of euros
brokering deals for face masks so the
political parties what are they doing
to combat this kind kind of corruption
well i think there's a growing uh
realization that germany does seem to
have a problem
uh in the area of political corruption
just a couple
of years ago the council of europe for
instance produced a report they said
the bundestag needs to do more needs to
introduce
a register of interests and links
between politicians and businesses
and that they were taking too long about
doing that particularly it's the cdu and
csu who've been unenthusiastic they make
the point
that politicians ought to be free in
their
choice of contacts but i think in the
wake of this scandal
we are seeing a change of mood and many
conservative politicians signaling
that they would be interested in a
particularly a register
of lobby interests in parliament
it's under pressure particularly from
opposition parties also from the
european commission incidentally
saying uh you know it's time to be to
have more transparency and more of a
legal basis
uh for the transparency of politicians
because it's so important for democracy
gw political correspondent simon young
with the latest tonight here in berlin
simon thank you